[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
Friday hello Friday
[Music]
back here again
[Music]
what Friday is here on the Tony Michaels
podcast it's bonehead of the week
you vote you decide we break it down in
the second hour so stay for all two full
hours with me
Tony Michaels and we will break down
bonehead of the week with Gabe Sanchez
my co-host in the second hour of the
show so stay with us all two hours like
we do every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific on YouTube Twitter and twitch
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button that's where you vote for
for bonehead of the week
is on the community tab on YouTube you
can also go to Twitter follow at Tony
Michaels pod we put up the poll there of
course we'll retweet that thing around
and around and around also download
every single episode don't forget to
miss
don't forget not to miss
on the audio version
Apple Spotify Google your favorite
directories make sure you leave us a
great review while you're there
subscribing we have all the trolls out
leaving horrible reviews you know it
really is something you know you're on
the right side of things when the
neo-nazis and the Elon scents and the
trumploodites
are all trolling you yeah
you know you're on the right side of
something they must they must not want
me to talk I don't know I guess that's
what is going on they don't like what I
say more than anything though they don't
like that you are here listening every
single weekday for two full hours this
audience is growing you are the best
audience in the world
we got a lot to talk about today
uh in legal news in legal news we have
updates
cash Patel actually testified uh before
a grand jury I read somewhere someone
said something about a grand jury
um Merrick Garland convening a grand
jury was means he's not serious about
something I I don't know there's a lot
of people really
um got the wins taken out of their sales
when they found out that the doj is
considering a special prosecutor
I guess
that people got their their undies in a
bunch here
I'm I'm here to tell you that honestly
I'm not I'm not opposed to a special
counselor I don't think I don't think
Merrick Garland on the department
Justice appointing a special counsel
is any less of
an investigative body frankly uh when a
special counsel and their team starts to
investigate someone each member on that
team has the powers of a United States
Attorney
so basically there's an entire team of
United States Attorney with their
authority of United States attorneys
investigating whatever it is they're
investigating a lot of people want to
compare it to the Mueller special
prosecutor but what you have to remember
is
who is in charge of doj
the entire process of the Mueller
investigation so I mean I get I get your
concerns I understand your concerns
about all this but that is why you must
you must take this election seriously
a lot of people are there's plenty of
video out there of these lines that are
happening especially around these
college campuses holy [ __ ] gen Z is not
[ __ ] around they're not [ __ ]
around that everyone's wondering why why
are the polls wrong I'll tell you why
the polls are wrong it's gen Z
[ __ ]
it's gen Z
I Gotta Give Them credit I gotta give
him credit I I didn't know
if the proof was it was gonna be in the
pudding but boy it does sure look like
the proof is in the pudding with this
gen Z they are not [ __ ] around they
are politically engaged they they do not
want these [ __ ] fascists taking away
their [ __ ] rights or telling them
what they can and cannot do
these are people with their entire
Futures in front of them
their entire futures
barely adults at this point
just becoming into adulthood
and making great adult decisions it
seems now we'll find out because you
know that's how elections work everyone
goes and casts their ballot and then
they count them and then we say okay
that's the decision that everyone made
that's kind of how democracy that's how
republics that's how constitutions
that's how liberalism that is how it
works
because we're not weak [ __ ]
snowflakes where we have to cry and
whine because the person that we want to
win didn't win
like uh I don't know Trump bumpers
you [ __ ] snowflakes
speaking of drum bubbers easy did you
see Elon Musk crying on Twitter this
this morning or last night whatever the
[ __ ] it was I know he was tweeting
advertisers are pulling their money oh I
don't I don't get to get the advertising
dollars because I'm a [ __ ] box yeah
that's how it works dummy
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] billionaire
class people all got together and
decided that money is speech and now
you're [ __ ] pissed off on your free
speech app that cost eight bucks to have
anyone hear what the [ __ ] you say
apparently that's how it's gonna be
now you're mad that these companies are
using their free speech you are a dumb
[ __ ] and anyone anyone who simps
for this stupid [ __ ] doesn't know how
capitalism works
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
I mean really honestly these these
crypto Bros these Elon stands these
these [ __ ] trumped up white dudes out
there that are simping for these [ __ ]
idiots on the internet man I gave you a
little more credit than this
you are some dumb [ __ ] if you
thought that corporations couldn't tell
Elon and Twitter to [ __ ] off it's their
money dummy
how did you not see this
really I gave Elon
way too much credit
I gained way too much credit way too
much [ __ ] credit
I thought he'd be smart enough towards
this deal when he had the chance
oh [ __ ] yeah I'm really I really believe
that he he was smart enough at least
smart enough to torch this deal
and not by Twitter
because he tweeted something think about
this he [ __ ] tweeted something
and this is going to cost him billions
of dollars a large percentage of his
wealth
oh he's tanked this [ __ ] I don't
know if you know but he hasn't just
broke California law it looks like he's
broke laws all around the [ __ ] world
there's gonna be class action lawsuits
against Twitter it's going to bankrupt
that [ __ ]
he's already in trouble with money
because he every single Advertiser
dumped every single [ __ ] dollar off
that off this app
because he's a dumbass and he just
didn't say hey I I got owned yeah I had
to buy Twitter because of a stupid tweet
and I didn't want my my stupid following
to to troll me forever and call me a
sellout so I had to buy Twitter I was
forced to buy it even though he tried
not to buy it he tried not to as hard as
he could he tried to get Twitter to back
out of the deal
what a great deal these shareholders
from Twitter got holy [ __ ] you talk
about capitalism101
the deal that these Twitter shareholders
got holy [ __ ]
imagine owning a stock and then someone
coming and wanting to pay you 30 percent
more and then danking
thanking the company of the stock they
just bought less than a month after they
[ __ ] take control of it
absolutely tanking that [ __ ]
he's not going to get anyone to pay
eight bucks
he's not gonna do it no one pays for
[ __ ] Twitter blue now
and
anyways on Twitter when you see someone
with a blue check from now on you know
that is a sign that they are a dumb buck
I mean it's just an indication that yep
you're a stupid bastard you pay any but
you're paying Elon eight bucks
so 12 people 12 more people see your
tweets
really [ __ ] dumb [ __ ]
no one in their right mind is gonna pay
eight bucks
so that you can provide content for Elon
what the [ __ ] out of here with that
[ __ ] No One's Gonna do that no but
no one's gonna I mean there's gonna be a
few dumb [ __ ] the Elon stands
we're gonna find out how many actual
fans he has
like we're gonna find out because the
largest percentage of the people who are
going to pay eight bucks
they sent for Elon and they're gonna
they're literally gonna send him eight
bucks like they send the Cheeto dust
kiwin on her money every [ __ ] month
to try to keep him afloat just try to
keep Twitter afloat for free speech
let's talk about that for a second I
think that's that's relevant here free
speech
we're coming up on an election here
where you get to use your speech
you get to use your speech for your vote
I think that speech you get to have your
voice counted
I practice my right to free speech every
single day as long as I don't break the
terms and service of the platforms that
I'm on which I probably do
they're just the trolls aren't good
enough out there to report me
yeah I'm daring yeah I don't know
here's the thing about freedoms and
rights
yeah the right
to own a gun in this country as long as
you're not a felon it's kind of funny
how they they sent for everyone on guns
but you can't own a gun for certain
people certain people can certain people
can't
seems kind of funny that there's
limitations to these rights
you know a gun you can own a gun in this
country
but you can also not own a gun
you follow me like you have the right to
own a firearm
also by granting you the right to own a
firearm you have the right knot
to own a firearm
you follow me
are you with me Elon Simpson shofar I
know you I know you guys love the
two-way Second Amendment PPU
even though elon's you know obviously
the
the face of two ebros
okay
so you have you have the right to own
and buy a firearm
because you have that right you have the
right not to they can't force you to own
one you follow are you still with me
now
when we're talking about Roe v Wade if
you go look at that decision what it
says is is you have the right
to get
an abortion and seek abortion services
because you are granted that right to
seek them
you have the right not
to seek them you follow me are you still
with me dumb [ __ ] because I
know you love the abortion thing I know
you trumped up white dudes you Elon Sims
oh you love talk about abortion even
though you never had one
[ __ ] idiot
and you won't have one you don't even
[ __ ] know
she had the right firearm you got it
right not to buy one you got the right
two seek abortion Services you had the
right not to seek abortion services are
you still with me
you have the freedom to speak
without being impeded by the government
okay are you following me
free speech
you had the right to remain silent you
ever heard of that one you had the right
not to speak they can't force you to
hell there's even another amendment the
fifth one
that Trump and all his allies love to
take so they can remain silent when it's
convenient so they don't incriminate
themselves
there's the freedom of religion too and
you have the right to have religion or
not have religion are you following how
rights and freedoms work
you [ __ ] idiots
now all these rights and freedoms that
I've been talking and I'm I'm trying to
pare it down dumb it down for the for
the Elon sense and the trolls that are
here I know you're here today because
you didn't probably like my [ __ ]
thumbnail you probably didn't like my
[ __ ] title
you just probably didn't like it you
weren't enthused about me going after
Elon
[Laughter]
shh
you have a lot of Rights and Freedoms in
this country
the one Freedom that you do not have
are you listening the one Freedom that
you do not have is freedom from
consequence
when you exercise your rights
you do not have that that is not a thing
that exists
a woman
who seeks out
abortion services
has the right to seek out those abortion
services but let me tell you over the
last few days I've watched a lot of
videos of women telling their stories
maybe you've maybe you Elon Stan should
you know
take a couple minutes and listen to I
don't know women about abortion
and abortion services
and how it affects them and their
families and their sisters
and their friends I don't know maybe you
should just take a couple minutes
but to think that there's no
consequences
two choosing to use abortion services
you really are brain dead
to think that there's no consequences
of owning and carrying a firearm
are not owning and carrying a firearm
there's consequences for speaking oh boy
Kyrie Irving
and Kanye West know that all too well
here the last several weeks
consequences are a [ __ ]
they're a [ __ ]
trust me I know
but every choice you make comes with
consequences some of them great
consequences some of the very bad
consequences
so choose how you exercise your freedom
wisely
I believe that's what the corporations
that are telling Elon Musk and Twitter
to [ __ ] off you're not getting our
advertising money or doing they're
choosing to use their their freedoms and
their rights
wisely
they're saying hey um that whole Twitter
thing you know how um you were gonna you
know
have moderation not fire half your
employees or something or and not you
know participate in letting hate speech
and misinformation and conspiracy
theories spread around and we're not
going to play that mess anymore we're
not gonna go play over there anymore
and if you think all these big
corporations all these big companies who
are [ __ ] pure blooded capitalist
don't see the writing on the wall and
that's why they're [ __ ] jumping
out of the ship of Twitter
Elon doesn't even see it he's like oh
they're they're they're they're
placating to the woke left
no they're placating to their own
interest what are you talking about the
woke left
they're placating to their own interest
they do not want people punishing them
economically because people have that
right and that choice
because you're a dumb [ __ ]
it's really simple
it really is simple
it's not complicated
and to think that the return on
investment of advertising dollars on
Twitter for these corporations
what's really that much in the first
place is kind of ridiculous
I mean it really is I mean there's
probably some Roi on their advertising
investment with Twitter
but more of more brand recognition than
anything
not a direct Roi so how easy was it for
these corporations just a [ __ ]
absolutely dump their advertising on
Twitter really easy that's why
it's really it really is [ __ ] stupid
stuff
that people think Elon Musk is smart
after you've watched what he's done in
the last week
he wasn't even smart enough to make sure
to have legal staff there to make sure
when he fired these employees he
wouldn't get his ass suit off
that's how [ __ ] dummy is
and really again I gave him way too much
[ __ ] credit that's the problem
is I gave him way too much credit the
thought to think that he was going to be
smart enough to back out of this deal
no way way dumber than I ever dreamed he
was
really [ __ ] stupid I mean he had a he
had an entire legal staff at Twitter
and they may have even told him hey
you're you can't I mean you can do that
but they're gonna [ __ ] sue you you're
you're
you're violating their employment rights
not just in California and God knows
what other states but Australia
apparently do this morning they're
reporting he's broken
Australian employment rate laws
it's bound to be a class action lawsuit
there too
so
there is freedom to every speech
but that you are not free from the
consequences
you are not
and the consequence that we need to lay
on these people who are clamoring on
about how Elon is the [ __ ] victim
here
from the woke left show them what the
[ __ ] woke left can do
that's what I'll tell you yeah you
mother wokers get out there and [ __ ]
vote [ __ ] these [ __ ]
[ __ ] em get out there and vote
cast your ballot for people who aren't
gonna whine and cry when they get
[ __ ] consequences put on them
aren't gonna [ __ ] piss and moan
when the choices that they made don't
slap them in the [ __ ] face
quit your [ __ ] bitching Elon pull up
your britches and hire back all those
people
that know how to run Twitter
and then and then start there and then
try to make it better dummy
and all you Elon stands out there you
people still still simping for this
idiot makes you look even dumber than he
is
oh we're crypto Bros and capitalism and
blah blah blockchain this Bitcoin that
deuts coin this the [ __ ] out of here you
are a bunch of dumb sons of [ __ ]
you have been duped you have been
[ __ ] duped to think that Elon Musk is
smart
and this is how the right wing works
baby
this is how it works
and it's plain to see right out in the
open
projection hypocrisy
the lack of decency the lack of humanity
emailing [ __ ] in the middle of
the night
because you ain't got the balls to
follow the law
because you got to make sure your fourth
quarter looks good
for your Saudi investors
hmm hey Elon Sims
did you know that the people who loaned
him the money to buy Twitter flew flew
planes into Towers on 911. did you
[ __ ] know that
did you know that you big Patriots out
there
you big sense for freedom of speech [ __ ]
out of here with that nonsense
you people are brain dead and mind
[ __ ]
you don't know what the freedom of
speech is you know you don't have
freedom is you know what Liberty is you
have no [ __ ] clue
dumber than dog [ __ ] you are
so that's that's my that's my uh
that's my take on freedom of speech and
Elon Musk and Twitter this morning I
know Gabe Sanchez is going to talk more
about this and he he knows some people
that worked at Twitter and that it I
think they some quit some got fired and
so um but
so we're gonna probably hear from Gabe
Sanchez on this a little bit but I have
a few things I want to show you today in
the shitless Roundup before we go to the
bonehead of the week it's super
important and we talk about a few of
these things one of them being The Oath
Keepers trial Stuart Rhodes the founder
of the oath keeper
is talking he's using his freedom of
speech this morning in an open court and
I don't think it's going as well as he
had hoped
um and he's not even being
cross-examined yet I don't I don't I
don't think but he took the stand which
um you would think is probably not
something that someone would want to do
but you know what hey more power to
Stewart to get up there and admit to
exactly what the prosecution is going to
accuse him of and more on that I promise
you we will talk about that because I
think that's super important in the lead
up to next week's election why it's so
important people really confused and
really pissed off at Merrick Garland I'm
going to explain to you why I think it's
not a bad thing and also
also Donald Trump running for president
in 2024 apparently
um this guy just can't shake loose all
his crimes and all these grand juries
that are gonna that are going to indict
him federally and that's what he's
trying to do is shake off these federal
indictments as he's toying with a with a
run for president of the United States I
dare you [ __ ] I [ __ ] dare you
let's do it let's do that [ __ ]
everyone's terrified of it I think it'll
be his absolute [ __ ] demise let's do
it let's do it everyone stick around
we'll be right back with a shitless
Roundup and we will be
back right after these messages
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product a part in blanket I've
got you covered pardon blanket
specifically Works to make you feel safe
and cozy after your involvement on
January 6th and if you're one of the
other members of Congress who also
helped with the attempted coup hard in
blanket will protect you too hard and
blanket is made of a sort of soft fleece
and a layer of sheep's wool and they're
a hundred percent made in the USA don't
delay and get your pardon blanket today
for just 99.99 actual pardons not
guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
Boy in the YouTube channel there's a
bunch of trolls I must have really
[ __ ] I must have really pissed him
off
[Music]
poor guys poor guys Four Guys four guys
that's how it happens that's how it
happens when you uh talk into a
microphone they get mad at you because
of what you say they really do get mad
at you at what you say
it pisses him off it pisses him off big
time really bad
they get they get they get infuriated
that you use your freedom of speech
against their stupid ideas that's that's
that's how it [ __ ] that's how it
works
that's why they yell and scream that's
why they that's why they do what they do
they're they're trying to yell and
scream and drown us out are they gonna
drown us out [ __ ] no they're not going
to drowned us out
no they are not going to drown this out
not going to happen
won't stop talking won't stop yelling
it won't happen I mean just just a pure
fact that they continue
in this jet
to do what they're doing
is more evidence that they are so
desperate
they are [ __ ] desperate
desperate for you not to hear my voice
Insanity insanity
so give me one second while I um
help the moderators here
maybe maybe fix this problem
oh my God
insanity but you know again that that's
what I've been saying is I'm telling you
I'm telling you they're they're after me
because I say stuff that you want to
hear
that's right
they're really [ __ ] butt hurt
over you hearing words that I say
and it scares them
it terrifies them
terrifies them
absolutely
gets in there girl
so they'll keep trying to go and go and
go
but they won't win
and the reason why they won't win
is because of you
because you continue to listen
and you continue to engage in your
democracy
so
if you want to beat the trolls if you
want to beat the fascist
just keep pressing
don't stop
don't look back
don't worry
we will drown them out with our vote
on Tuesday
I've got a video I want to show you so
let's do this let's go to the [ __ ] list
Roundup where we round up all the Tweety
tweets and trendy Trends because I have
a lot of video I want to show you Gabe
Sanchez is going to be joining us very
soon he is still working on some of the
bonehead of the week
Graphics so we can do bone of the week
in the second hour remember bonehead of
the week every single Friday every
Friday here on the Tony Michaels podcast
so let's do the [ __ ] list Roundup we'll
be start the countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Ed the point of the show where we round
up all the Tweety tweets and the trendy
Trends here on the Tony Michaels podcast
so let's start with this let's start
with the video here and let's see I
might have to refresh there was a video
that I found someone sent me
someone tagged me on I think and right
before yeah here it is right before I
want to show you uh Gen X or no gen Z
excuse me
gen Z watch this watch this this is uh
let's see where is this this is uh
at UT Austin University of Texas Austin
yeah let's let's watch this video here
of the students standing in line to vote
foreign
are you wondering if um these students
are standing in line to
vote for a fascist
you wondering I'm not wondering okay
you seen that dedicated
[Music]
I'm not [ __ ] around
not
[ __ ] around this generation's gonna
do this
so if you're wondering if you're
wondering if the reason why I've been
saying and the reason why others have
been saying just in the last few days
that hey these polls that we've been
seeing Oh my God
they're [ __ ] dead wrong they're dead
wrong that's because
that's because they're not polling
gen Z
that's why
it's insanity but
what are you gonna do oh here's a great
tweet
um from Mike scones he's
I don't want to make a broad
generalization oh this is going to piss
the trolls off here hey trolls are you
listening I don't want to make a broad
generalization but you have to admit
it's at least interesting that everyone
who likes Elon Musk is The Biggest Loser
you have ever met
the biggest [ __ ] loser you've ever
met if you're an Elon Stan that is with
the category that you fit in
um his tweet blew up apparently
you got a lot of likes a lot of retweets
he said wow this really blew up I feel
like one of his cars oh [ __ ] sweet Elon
Burns sweet Elon burns the smoke you can
feel the smoke
um Elon Musk is just not down for
capitalism this morning he doesn't
understand it
um here's his here's his uh here's his
tweet
about it about um him being a crybaby
little [ __ ] because that's what he is
Elon says this morning Twitter has a
massive drop in Revenue
I thought you were a great business
person I really did think you were a
great business person like I I thought
that
you would be a good business person
due to the activist groups pressuring
advertisers what are you talking about
one there was one big agency that was
like no we're not gonna We're not gonna
do that kind of [ __ ]
and they pulled they pulled hundreds of
millions of dollars of advertising from
Twitter and one Fell Swoop from one
agency
even though nothing has changed with
content moderation and we did everything
we could to appease the activists get
the [ __ ] out of here what are you
talking about
there's no one out protesting
Twitter you [ __ ] fired 3 700 people
this morning and you're supposed to be a
job creator
listen to this he's he's laying off 3
700 workers so he can make the the other
workers that are going to remain work 90
hours a week
sounds like a populist to me sounds like
a man of the people the [ __ ] out of here
fun goes on to cry he says extremely
messed up
they're trying to destroy free speech in
America
oh these corporations they they have to
bow at my feet they must they must they
must do what I demand which is pay me
advertising dollars you are a dumb
[ __ ]
we've already been through this before
we've been telling you bastards for
years that money shouldn't be speech but
you you clearly do not understand how
capitalism Works money is speech and
capitalism what do you [ __ ] think
capitalism actually is
it's a democracy you get to vote with
money you get to decide who to give it
to and what products to give it to
capitalism even though it may not be the
greatest form of a democracy it truly is
and you get to vote with your money
so these corporations are just taking
their vote on you Elon
they're using their freedom of speech
not to give you their [ __ ] money
and really honestly by announcing it and
saying it out loud they're even telling
you more with their freedom of speech to
[ __ ] off
and that you're ruining a platform that
they will be willing to give advertising
dollars to but you're ruining it
whoosh
he really is a stupid he really is a
stupid bastard
he is he's just a dumb [ __ ]
I don't know how else to explain it
and again I gave him way more credit
than what he'd ever deserved I really
thought Elon was smart enough not to
make this decision
I really thought
he was smart enough
but he's clearly not
clearly he is not
okay let's do
here's what I said
if I can there we go
I said money is speech [ __ ] swear we
knew that's the rules billionaires like
you choose to live under
they don't want to give labor speech
they don't want to give people speech
they want all the speech for themselves
the more money the more speech
that's what they want
everyone's wondering what's happening in
the YouTube chat with all the trolls
they're terrified
they're terrified
they're terrified of me saying exactly
what I'm saying and pointing out what
I'm pointing out
that's why they're in the chat that's
why they're doing what they're doing
they're terrified of us speaking out
everyone keeps saying to talk to Robin
it's probably because of the trolls
is probably why
is what's going on
but they're mad they're mad because it's
not going the way that they want
and they're about to get a huge Hammer
dropped on them on Tuesday because
that's gonna go way worse than what they
want
way worse
than what they want I just showed you
the video and the numbers are getting
worse and worse but I want to show you a
video though
I want to show you a video here
I want to show you a video and Robin
don't don't worry too much about the
trolls we'll we'll try to get them fixed
here in a minute we'll try to get them
fixed here in a minute just just let
them keep keep building new accounts
they're not going to stop they're not
going to stop building new accounts so
we'll get them taken care of here in a
minute when I've got a little more help
on my hands but here is here is
this is a great video you remember the
video last week that we showed
um
that was Ben Shapiro
and he was uh
he was he was talking about how he's in
support of trans rights remember that
video
same [ __ ] made this video this
this video is hilarious
this this video is called Elon is dead
watch this
you're kidding
oh my God
that is unbelievable
it's true it's true oh my God
oh this should really
a little bit here that is unbelievable
it's true it's true oh my God
that's hilarious
oh
Bernie Sanders Justin t brown with the
win on that video this morning
Justin t brown with the win on that
video this morning okay let's let's uh
let's see what else do we have here on
the agenda
um oh yes remember how I've been saying
they really want the Kerry Lake
election that's the one they want they
want it bad in Arizona
this is Trader TV News Network war room
is apparently on every single Trader TV
News Network it's syndicated
syndicated treason
over there on Lindell TV and any other
Trader News Network but here is
um Sonny Borelli he's an Arizona state
senator he's a republican imagine he's
an election denier
and he also wants to lock people up
remember how these [ __ ] these people
have been saying for for weeks and weeks
and weeks you can't lock up your
political enemies
can't lock up your political enemies
well here's Sonny listen this
is Adrian Fontes and Katie Hobbs because
they were Cancun together okay and I
would not be surprised if they're
manipulating
state
wow so people that work within the
secretaries within the uh Maricopa
County Office you believe do you believe
that the K the people that tried to hide
this information because you now have a
massive cut what you've got is a
cover-up do you think that they're
personally criminally liable I believe
so I believe so they need to be held
accountable in any way possible
okay so he they really think that
they're gonna bang up listen to this
this is this is super important they
think they're gonna bang up
the Democratic nominees for these races
because they were government officials
before this is a guy who's a current
government official
in Arizona
calling for his political enemies to be
locked up because they followed their
Duty and there's not a trace not a sign
they can't point to one piece of
evidence not one in Arizona the two
thousand mules people that like the
people who [ __ ] made the movie
they're in jail right now I don't know
if you people know that
the people who [ __ ] produce the movie
The Dinesh D'Souza movie
based on the book that he's had to
[ __ ] he has to [ __ ] reprint
because of defamation lies inside the
book those [ __ ] are in in jail
right now for contempt
you know why they're in jail for
contempt the reason why the people who
made 2 000 meals and that's the weapon
that they're using in Arizona to try to
get Kerry Lake elected the reason why
the [ __ ] are in jail
and and for contempt is because they
make a they make a lot of [ __ ] claims
in that movie
and say that an FBI informant gave them
that [ __ ] information
and it's defamatory
and they're being sued because of the
defamation because that's what happens
see when you [ __ ] take little morsels
of facts and you twist them on someone
and you try to destroy their livelihood
it's defamation and you can be [ __ ]
sued
and they are being sued and the and the
[ __ ] judge said no you're gonna tell
me who this FBI informant is and and
because they want to know if it's
[ __ ] real
and the judge told them you either tell
me who the FBI informant is of this
information or you admit that it's
[ __ ] fake and it's [ __ ] they
won't do either so they're held and
contempt until they do one or the other
because it's all [ __ ] there's no FBI
informant the FBI has already spoke out
in the case saying we don't if there's
an FBI informant we don't give a [ __ ] if
they out that person
the FBI has even said it because the FBI
knows there's no [ __ ] informant
and these people are sitting in jail
right now
because they won't come out and say it's
all horseshit it's all a bunch of
[ __ ] garbage they made it up
see it used to be when you made up
stories you would make a movie and you
it would just be a [ __ ] it's a movie
we are at the intersection of
WrestleMania in real life
and these [ __ ] boneheads
don't understand the consequences of
their speech
you have the right
you have the right
to speak but you're not free from the
consequences
like these folks who had the right to
say that they had an FBI informant and
all this [ __ ] blah blah blah defamation
defamation defamation
you have the right to say that [ __ ]
but you are not free from the
consequences
and the judge is saying this the proof
that you have that you're saying you
have that makes this not defamation show
it to me show it to me
and they won't do it because they don't
have it
that's what the judge knows that's why
the judge is doing what they're doing
and that's why they're so desperate in
Arizona and why they've weaponized this
2 000 mules we've done several [ __ ]
reports here on that clean Q Anon
elections USA
where they're [ __ ] trying to
intimidate people at the ballot boxes
the drop boxes for mail-in and absentee
ballots which is you can legally drop
yours and your family members balance in
those boxes
and they're using intimidation tactics
and the federal judge said no you cannot
do that you can't [ __ ] do it
so now they're taking after new tactics
which is to weaponize other lies
that's what they do that's what the
right does
what do you think what do you think the
attack on Paul Pelosi was
I was weaponizing lies
yeah Rob and a few other people are
saying that Elon was slapped with a fact
check of course he was
of course he was they've been slapping
fact checks on the White House as if
they're burning the White House for days
you [ __ ] break
again I'm telling you this Twitter thing
and it's the same thing it's the same
thing as this that I'm talking about
it's the same [ __ ] weaponizing lies
why do you think Elon Musk wants to
[ __ ] open up Twitter to where anyone
can say anything and spread any kind of
information with the blue check that
they possibly can on November 7th do you
know what day November 7th is that's
Monday
that's the day before election day in
this country
I mean any good business decision that
you have is probably worth waiting I
don't know maybe a week or two
of implementing
he can't wait though
I mean he might have been told
who knows what his investors have told
him he had to borrow the money from the
people who flew planes into [ __ ]
buildings
but again that's why they're spreading
this horse [ __ ] like 2 000 mules and
this idea that people who drop ballots
and drop boxes are doing something
illegal are that mail-in voting is bad
are that absentee voting is bad that
early voting is bad it's all a bunch of
[ __ ] horse [ __ ] to convince dumb
[ __ ] of stupid stuff
like the fact that Elon Musk is smart
he's not smart you dumb [ __ ]
you believing it does not make it true
but that's why they want to win Arizona
the reason why they want to wear and win
Arizona is because Carrie lake is the
best propagandist that they have on the
ballot that can still possibly win
that's it that that's what it is because
it's all [ __ ] propaganda watch this
clip from Fox News watch this if you
will have been in the past someone you
would self-describe as a Democrat would
you raise your hand
okay look at this group of people
take notice
all kind of looking at each other this
isn't rigged at all it's on Fox News you
can trust this with your life now watch
all right and now of you which by the
way is the majority of our panel if you
have or intend to vote Republican in
this midterm election would you raise
your hand
no not faked at all not faked at all
nope not faked at all
this is again again it's it's more the
same stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] that
they've been feeding us for [ __ ]
years
that somehow he has big support
he does have big support
on from white nationalist
from white supremacist from [ __ ]
neo-nazis
listen
just just in the last few weeks these
trolls that have been [ __ ] coming
after me the ones that were in the chat
today every [ __ ] one of them they've
threatened gave Sanchez's life
telling him he better go back to where
he came from Chicago is where he came
from
threatening his life
posting pictures of my underage children
on Twitter
that's right
and every time you go to these accounts
and you see what they're liking what
they're sharing it's the same
[ __ ] fascist [ __ ] same
fascist [ __ ]
they're scared of you
I mean yeah they [ __ ] hate me because
I talk right
and you listen but they're really
terrified of you
they don't they don't they could give
two shits about me
other other than I talk and you listen
that's why they [ __ ] attack me they
want me to shut the [ __ ] up
because if I don't tell you these things
you may not tell the three people that
I've been telling you to tell and they
those three people may not tell those
three people because that's what we got
to do you have to encourage three people
to vote to lean in and engage in your
democracy
and those three people must encourage
three more people that is how this works
that is how you get a movement of We the
People
it's most important
oh uh um Laura ask here on YouTube did I
hear that right they posted Tony's yeah
yeah that's right
that is right
they went they went to my wife's
Facebook page they found out who my wife
is they'd screen grabbed pictures of my
children and were posting them on
Twitter
and they think they think it's gonna
scare me off
that's what they think that's what they
believe
and by scaring me off that means you
won't you won't have the opportunity to
listen
to my re my freedom of speech
because truly they're scared of you
and they should be
people are [ __ ] sick and tired of
their Nazi [ __ ] I know you are
I'm sick and tired of it
I know a lot of people that are sick and
tired of it
I know people who are not who are not
politically engaged that are sick and
tired of of [ __ ] boneheads saying
crazy ass chewing on [ __ ]
talking about people's genitalia and
what bathrooms you can go into
people are tired of it people who don't
even [ __ ] give a [ __ ] about politics
are tired of hearing that they aren't
gonna they're gonna ban Book Fairs
they're not gonna let your kids read the
books they want to read
that you're gonna force people to be
Christians get the [ __ ] out of here with
that nonsense Americans don't want that
garbage
so yeah yeah they're after me
they're after me because they they got
to get you to stop listening to
pro-democracy speech
what do you think the whole [ __ ]
Twitter Elon buying Twitter thing is is
to open up the floodgates so there's
more [ __ ] post about q and on
conspiracy theories driving people to go
try and assassinate politicians with
hammers
what do you think it's about
they don't want you to hear that you
should go vote to change your to protect
your way of life and to protect your
democracy but to make change in our
society because they don't want that
change
they're terrified of equality and equity
terrified of it
they're white supremacists
they don't want to change the status quo
and they definitely definitely don't
want me talking to you telling you how
to change the status quo
which is too engaged to talk to people
ask them [ __ ] questions simple
questions not get down in the weeds like
a bunch of [ __ ]
bourgeois leftists
that's why they [ __ ] hate me
but you must you must engage
it's not it's not so important now that
you just vote
it really isn't
it is more important that you actually
do the things that democracies do
which is message spread the narrative
propagate what is right
an equality and equity in our world
today and in our society today is what
we should strive for
that Liberty of all people no matter who
the [ __ ] they are
I want I want Elon Musk to have the
right to be a dumb [ __ ]
and to say stupid [ __ ] [ __ ]
because if he's allowed that right
you're allowed that right
if a woman in this country is allowed to
make her medical decisions between her
and her doctor
my daughter
will be allowed my wife my mother
will be allowed how don't you understand
this we watched a video yesterday you
[ __ ] Elon sense you Trump bumpers
fake Gabe Trump copy machines
how don't you know this when you take
away when you let these morons slowly
take away the rights of others they're
coming for you too
so stand up lean in engage in your
democracy it is so important and crucial
in this time in history
because they're not going to stop
they're not going to relent
these people are desperate
they're desperate and they're hanging on
to desperate lies
and they're getting worse and worse and
worse
and less convincing every [ __ ]
day
but we cannot stop we can not back down
from these threats
to our [ __ ] way of life
we must vote
and we must engage
in our democracy
it's crucially important I want to show
you another video here speaking of
engaging
especially with Elon Musk so Elon Musk
decided it would be funny
if he tweeted out a picture of a sweater
that AOC has in her merch store right
and I think it was like 58 bucks or
something like that which really
honestly
if you do the math
really it's it's not that ridiculous to
think
that a sweater a customized sweater
would be you know 58 bucks
it really isn't
but Elon thinks it is
and now it's kind of Rich because I'm
not even gonna go too far into the weeds
but on the Tesla store they have
sweaters for twice the price
literally literally twice the price oh
my God
he really is grasping at straws now I
know what he's doing here you know he's
picking on a woman is what he's doing
because he's a he's a [ __ ] snowflake
he's he's the king of the incels
that's what he's that's what he's doing
right but in pure pure AOC fashion and
this is what I love about her most
because I don't agree with AOC on
everything
I mean obviously the people in her in
her in her constituency in her District
agree with a lot because they
overwhelmingly vote for her
but this here oh my God she really puts
him in his place this video here now
again this is just like chat from her
cell phone she's in her small apartment
in the Bronx
she's eating chicken strips with her dog
and she absolutely destroys destroys
Elon Musk watch this I was at a
community event
in the Bronson Co-op City
I want to get home
I see a text from my team saying
hey let me know if you need any help
with this you hear the dog snoring in
the background
we had that problem here in once a while
he's not here but my dog sits on the
chair next next to my desk here once a
while he's snoring over there but you
can hear the dog in the background but
she's eating chicken strips burning
elong let's let's keep going this Elon
stuff
and I was like what
so I pulled my Twitter app
and it's like gone like
when you pull up your mentions and stuff
like that it's just like literally like
a blank screen totally gone
and I was like hmm that's weird
so it turns out
we got under a certain little
billionaire skin
[Music]
because I made fun of this silly little
plan
to charge people for verification and
priority placement
if you pay eight dollars for people to
see your tweets more
and get silly
okay so within I mean we're not even a
minute into this right we're not even a
minute and she's destroying the fact
that Elon even dreaming that this idea
that he's gonna charge eight bucks for
people to be verified and to get their
tweet seen more it's just absolutely
[ __ ] ridiculous like it's just [ __ ]
even on its face it's ridiculous that he
thought that this was gonna be a good
idea like that people thought that they
were gonna like this [ __ ] come on get
the [ __ ] out of here but but watch as
she Burns him down even more over the
merch so anyways it made a man
so then
he decides to like tweet a screenshot of
our campaign store
because our sweatshirts are like 50 to
58 dollars
as some kind of like gotcha that like
other people
pay money for goods emphasis on real
Goods
um in the world
and uh but here's the thing is that
unlike Elon Musk
all the workers with our campaign
our campaign is unionized we pay full
health care
we have other benefits like child care
stipends
proceeds go to community Investments
like tutoring kids in underserved
communities especially after covid
we do things
for society
with the resources that are entrusted to
us
billion
so she's gonna
I mean absolutely tearing down his house
as she's eating chicken strips how
[ __ ] beautiful is this
how [ __ ] beautiful is this and really
honestly you know I would I would love
to make an easy enemy out of AOC oh it's
easy it's easy
just ask anyone how easy it is to be her
enemy but this makes me love her so much
and again I disagree with her on a lot
of stuff
and what I mean is we we have we I have
personal disagreements on the actual
policy line by line right
but here she is explaining this so well
that these billionaires are actually the
[ __ ] snowflakes they have no [ __ ]
clue they have no
unfucking unfucking Godly clue
what is actually going on
Elon Musk the reason why he thinks he
can do what he can do by this morning
firing 3 700 workers or 27 whatever the
[ __ ] number thousands of workers
while AOC is burning him on a video
showing how she's unionized her [ __ ]
her her employees get health care the
reason why is because he's way out of
touch
he's just absolutely 100 way out of
touch
way out of touch so much so that he
thinks everyone's gonna pay him eight
dollars to have Twitter
that's how out of touch is
and he thought it was going to be a good
idea to attack her for a 58 dollar
sweater
on her [ __ ] merch store let's
continue in errors
pocket the change
and take that extra money to Wall Street
so
whenever you have one person
that has a mask that much socially
influential wealth
usually off of the backs of skimming off
of an underpaying working people or
exploiting them or the planet in some
way
like when they've amassed that much
[Music]
it does not help Society
in fact it hurts Society
so this is just your annual
daily minute reminder that indeed every
billionaire is a policy failure in a
country that does not guarantee Health
Care
and that has enormous amounts of poverty
do you hear the dog do you hear the dog
do you hear the dog in the background oh
my God it's so beautiful and this is
what I'm talking about
this is what I'm talking about she is
shooting this
from from her cell phone in her small
apartment eating chicken strips while
the dogs snorting in the phone
snoring
all the while Elon Musk in this moment
when she was making this video is making
plans to email to fire thousands of
employees of Twitter thousands of them
while because he thinks it's a sick burn
that that AOC sells a piece of merch on
her website that that costs 58 which
provides health care benefits
it provides tutoring and her supporters
are willing to pay the 58 bucks so all
that stuff gets provided to her campaign
her staff those children getting
tutoring
wow let's continue
and you can buy from our shop
I would get right below also
there's something that is so satisfying
about
just being here in the Bronx in
Parkchester
with my dog
and we have a billionaire
pressed like the rest
it was American Dream Baby
here she is sitting from a cell phone a
congresswoman in a small District in New
York who they all hate who they all hate
owning absolutely owning and living rent
free inside of a Billionaire's mind
inside of a Billionaire's mind this is I
honestly folks we have to keep at this
and she's completely right we have to
keep at this we have to keep after him
um here's a great meme that I found Elon
posted something that was very similar
to this now let me see if I can
pull the banner down here so you can see
it
um
so here it says
ending world hunger
six billion no you won 44 billion for
Twitter yay yay yay he did a Starbucks
thing I don't know if you guys seen this
he had a Starbucks meme where people
were crying that they had to pay eight
bucks for Twitter but they'd pay eight
bucks for a Starbucks what does that
tell you about people not what I I Elon
listen to me if people are willing to
pay
eight dollars
for a latte or whatever the [ __ ] you get
at Starbucks
but they're not willing to pay eight
bucks for Twitter what does that tell
you about your Eight dollar plan for
Twitter dummy what does that tell you
about it
it says more about your plan than it
does about the Starbucks
you [ __ ] idiot
oh my God he really is a [ __ ]
bonehead he really is okay um I got um
let's see I got some more video I want
to show you here
um
and and the reason why is because I want
to show you something that I've been
saying and a lot of people say Hal
Spark's been saying this too I don't
know I watch Hal every once in a while
but I don't have time to check out every
single piece of content but I've been
saying this for a long time that his
following is all [ __ ] fake it's all
[ __ ] fake the rallies are [ __ ]
fake it's the same [ __ ] sheep
Gathering up in the old lonely pasture
like I've been saying this for a long
time same bumfuckers behind him they
just like rearrange him put new shirts
on them different hats give them
different signs same [ __ ] no
well here's what happens see a lot of
these people come to gather up a crowd
in a field somewhere because he can't
rent a [ __ ] venue because he owes too
much too many people too many too much
money in these big bigger cities
like literally he owned he owes he owes
City governments millions of dollars
that they've spent in protecting
when he comes to rallies and he hasn't
paid his [ __ ] bills
so he's got to go to these you know
these
pastures these these [ __ ] livestock
fields
these hay fields that they mowed
and they gotta throw him like outside
that's the only way they can do these
things and it's the same [ __ ]
that show up but you know they gather up
several hundred from the kind of the
local area and they gather them up
because they want to sell them all the
[ __ ] merch right shut up all the
[ __ ] tents these people come and they
they sell all these same people
it's [ __ ] weird listen to these guys
apparently this one it's uh is 39th time
and the other one's his 45th time listen
to this Gabe Sanchez have you have you
seen this video these guys talking about
how they
where they [ __ ] and where they shower
have you seen this no I have not seen
this one okay well well um we'll we'll
we'll watch this here and we'll talk
about where they sit and shower after
where do you go to the bathroom are you
are you sleeping there on the concrete
like walk us through how a front row Joe
survives out on these locations for a
day's on end we sleep in our cars or I
even have a car tent that sit up and
sleep in
um I take my showers at Planet Fitness I
got a membership just take showers oh
that's smart that's smart so for ten
dollars a month you can get a shower
anywhere in America you have to get the
black car the 22.99 a month but still
that's worth it good to know that where
do you
I have I have several friends who have
done uh and and currently are doing like
the van life type of thing right right
you mean where like you build a van to
be kind of like a small apartment or
tiny houses yeah people have done it
with ambulances they're typically just
the um
they're the
um
the trainer I think the name is the
trainer uh is what the the brand is or
the the model of the of the the Sprinter
it's yeah the Sprint today yeah the
Sprinter that's what it is which is the
very come on man I know I know there's
the there's the long one you typically
see them like they're like the delivery
trucks that a lot of the Amazon delivery
and FedEx have there's even an extended
version which is crazy but that's really
big van life at that point that yeah
yeah and uh so I have friends who have
retrofitted those vans and have done the
van life and did that years ago before
it kind of like became this
popular thing right now on this trend
but they themselves also uh got a gym
membership so like that idea is not
crazy but the fact that these guys are
sitting in a pile of dirt waiting for a
rally to happen
is hilarious
like oh it's beautiful
like nothing nothing better nothing
better than to prove that all his his
big crowds it's all the same
[ __ ] driving around the country
living in their cars taking showers at
at Planet Fitness yeah right like that's
what they're doing he's like well you
got to get the black card it's 29.99
yeah well I mean you know that doesn't
matter I mean look everybody knows that
Gabe saying you're the one sitting out
for days on end waiting for a dude who
keeps grifting money from you that
you've probably got in the second or
third mortgage on your home
refinanced you've probably spent your
child's college fund if there was one
you sold your cars you clearly don't
have any sort of uh like I don't know if
this guy is retired or if he just just
stopped going to work one day and they
got matching shirts and matching mom
jeans that's for sure I mean I think
they're I mean obviously their new job
whether they had a job before is now
just
on the they're they're like uh
not groupies right not Band-Aids but
they're I mean I don't know they're just
like I guess they're just sheep at the
end of the day right right well I mean
that's what they do is they herd up the
same sheep in the same lonely pasture
right like that's that's how they do it
I love I love how though this is the
pre-coverage of the rally right yeah the
free coverages to talk about is to give
a lesson hey if you want to be a groupie
this is how you do it like here's the
how to where to [ __ ] where to go to the
bathroom where to shower at if you're
you know it's almost like a lot of the
same people been showing up like God
damn man just go get a go get a [ __ ]
membership at Planet Fitness and take a
[ __ ] shower every once in a while
Jesus Christ like you're not doing this
whole this this whole Trump sheet thing
right right like yeah it's I mean you
know it's uh it's sad and funny all at
the same time like you see these people
they keep showing up they're like it's
my 30th round it's my 45th rally 45
let's go it's uh it's really sad it's
really pathetic I mean like to have
someone and obviously like the
the the reaction that when you're like
wait wait you've gone to 45 of these
rallies like that's what you're that's
what you're doing with your life right
now and they're like oh well you don't
see a lot of people at a Joe Biden rally
it's like well one Joe Biden is not
running right two you know they're like
well you don't he is the president he
doesn't need to have that yeah even in
2020 they're like oh man it's compared
well it's like yeah they're practicing
safe distancing you know kind of covered
and he still whooped your ass and he's
still look the guy killed you the guy
who was [ __ ] sleeping in his basement
and love to eat ice cream cones beat
your guy who was actively doing he he
can't even he can't even put two
thoughts together this Joe Biden that's
what they say he can't put two thoughts
get he's he's lost all cognitive he's
cognitively he's disappeared I mean he
should be impeached for it he can't even
speak Gabe right he is he is definitely
not fit to be present but he definitely
whipped Donald Trump's ass more 8
million more people went you know what
I'll go with that guy then right like
literally is that their thought process
because I really don't understand their
thought their thought process much um
what is a rhetoric says yeah he's an
attention or oh yeah yeah or no he's not
he's saying oh Joe Biden's not yeah I I
I thought he was talking about Trump
well I mean it is the same right he is
Trump he's an intention [ __ ] Biden is
not right right right well it happens I
mean the guy is a narcissist like he
loves to he's like oh yeah let me dance
like this like it looks like the [ __ ]
hand job damn someone someone said the
other day on Twitter I think they said
why does it look like he's jerking off
two giraffes from when he danced because
that's literally like what else is that
high up right right I mean you know it's
uh it's it's I don't know pretty crazy
talking about a jerk off Trump and a
jerk off he really [ __ ] this one up
right so one day before Tish James files
the the civil suit against the Trump
organization where she's going to cut
him down like a fresh cut tree right
because of all the fraud he's he's right
on the state of New York he opened up a
trump organ we talked about this a
little bit he's opened up a yeah this
was the is it Delaware I think it's a
Delaware Corporation yeah it's always
it's always Delaware but this this was
announced uh this came out that he he
was trying to or started uh uh the Trump
or two right it was I think it was on
either the Thursday the day 9 of the Jan
6 committee or if it was the Friday
after I forget which one
um because I was I was in I was in funny
enough I was in New York at the time
dude scared that they're gonna take his
money because he did it to move cash
right and he's doing it to move assets
also why would you like come up with a
better name man like if you're trying to
wow you're right but I need something
well like when I call it Trump
organization too
guys someone in the thread I think said
like um he might as well named it here's
where I'm moving my ass here's where I'm
illegally moving my assets to LLC it is
insane that this guy I mean he's like
literally you know some sometimes people
say hey if you really want to hide
something hide them in plain sight but
this doesn't really work in this way
like if you're gonna go Trump org one
under federal investigation
we should change it to Trump or two no
one will ever look there wink wink no
one like no one will ever ever catch on
to that but a Mueller she wrote uh
breaks the news here from the Supreme
Court of the state of New York um this
is very important that just uh the
Justice ingaran I think is how you say
it has granted the New York attorney
general Tish James motion for
preliminary injunction and the
appointment of a monitor which is super
important in this case James alleged
Donald was committing fraud by hiding
assets in a new company called Trump or
two by the way that's the Delaware
Corporation they open James allege that
in open court the Justice agreed with
her and said not only not only is there
an injunction on this moving assets to
this corporation that you set up in
Delaware now we're going to have a
monitor now he freaked out last night on
stage about this right can you can you
find that clip and then before we get a
bonus he freaked the [ __ ] out about this
on stage and he he said apparently he
said that they were stealing his assets
which already tells me he knows the
state of New York is gonna get his
[ __ ] money like he already knows this
that's why he set up Trump or two to try
to hide the money and that's why he's
saying what he's saying on stage when
the judge appoints a monitor because
when they appoint a monitor apparently
not only is this minor going to make
sure he isn't transferring assets
they're going to collect up what assets
he has to figure out how much he
actually can pay the state in New York
because that is a really big question in
this case is can he even pay them money
right and the reason why is because he
may owe way more [ __ ] money on these
properties than what they're even worth
he that may be how he oh yeah well we
already know that right like so so the
liability the the actual when you when
you do the asset versus the liability
sheet it's going to be in the red the
same way as elon's kind of you know
gonna bankrupt Twitter within a manner
of a couple [ __ ] weeks here I mean it
just
isn't it funny how Donald Trump and Elon
Musk are known as like oh they're such
great business people they're so smart
and like they make the stupidest the
stupidest [ __ ] decisions right now
terrible terrible right now
I'm not saying that every business
decision has to be perfect I mean
obviously obviously you always have make
decisions that have unintended
consequences and right in any anything
that you do but Jesus Christ what what
could possibly go wrong when you're
you're you're not only is your business
under criminal indictment and in trial
in New York now you have the Attorney
General going to file a civil lawsuit
against you to try to take it down but
so you think it's a good idea to open up
a a [ __ ] Corporation in another state
to try to hide your assets criminally
possibly yeah that sounds like a great
idea you really gotta I don't know man
like there is certainly a trend amongst
conservative Free Speech libertarian
also business people yeah who want to
run their business and then when [ __ ]
goes sideways because they made a very
poor business decision until in terms of
the uh I want a grift money from you I
want to steal money from you I want to
make a new organization to remove myself
from this other organization so I can
still keep my money if I'm trying to buy
Twitter to own the libs like all of
these like Conservative Business
decisions that's made and they propped
up by people that are all of their Sims
I mean we're literally watching this in
real time I've Got Friends at Twitter
and also I've got some other friends who
have friends at Twitter obviously
where the things that are being said
right now that like there are people at
the company they're like put me out of
my [ __ ] misery like I hope I get that
[ __ ] email that says I don't have a
job because they don't want to work
there they don't want to work there and
a lot of them I mean the last like you
know what uh week a week and a half two
weeks or whatever it's been non-stop
stress to be like hey you have to hit
this
um
this deadline right I mean he took over
on the 30th the 31st I forget which day
right it's it's hard to tell now how
fast he's tanked it I mean you would
think it would have took him at least
six months or a year in private chance
we I was like is it gonna be 24 months
36 months I really get I really gave
this guy way too much credit I mean I
said by the end of Q2 I Believe by the
end of Q2 2023 Twitter will be a [ __ ]
like it'll be a [ __ ] like 4chan troll
Farm
uh I mean like look if you're killing
the moderation team and you're trying to
charge people to uh send I don't know if
you heard about this one of the other
ways was one they were going to say like
all right if you want to view this
content you got a paywall the video
right so like wait wait so so if I'm a
content creator if I'm posting you can
put up a gate and say you have to pay to
watch this video on so you're gonna make
you can make your followers pay to watch
the video Yeah Yeah so basically if they
subscribe to you then I guess they would
get it off or like you know or they
would be able to see it it's a whole
thing now the other thing that I'm like
what which that that really that that
component there that one almost makes a
little bit of sense that right that
one's not a big deal right but that one
doesn't that one doesn't really confuse
me as much and and the reason why is
because you expect followers of a
content creator because we you create a
lot of content we create a lot of
content sometimes content creators are
like hey I I need some support we ask
for support all the time that's how we
make the content did you guys buy the
merch you give us tips every once in a
while some people set it up monthly like
there's ways that you support content
creators to keep them I don't know
creating content right right and that
that one kind of makes sense that one
kind of if you had certain if you had
certain types of content sure but then
there's also a part of me that's like
look do two things are gonna happen one
people are not gonna buy it or one
person's gonna buy it and they're just
gonna leak it online and spread it
around and then it becomes this whole
thing of like who owns the content and
right because you got a lot of that like
with patreon and everything right that's
why I don't really like [ __ ] patreon
personally number one because patreon
takes a huge [ __ ] cut yeah what of
what that of what those supporters of
that Creator
um actually give them so what hap what
ends up happening is that patreon ends
up owning the largest majority of the
[ __ ] content right they actually own
the content at that point I mean in a
sort of roundabout way yeah I mean you
can pull it down but still they're still
taking a huge percentage of the
supporters money for the content creator
so I'm not really a fan of that kind of
[ __ ] thing I I would never we don't
gate our content and I don't know that I
would ever get our content it just it it
it I I feel like if you really truly are
a supporter then you'll support court
right yeah that you don't you don't have
to gate it to to charge someone for them
to see it and that you're right they're
making a also is another assumption
because like people want when they're on
Twitter right like some people want to
remain anonymous which is a whole idea
of like I don't want to pay to verify
who I am right especially we've got Bots
and trolls so then you've got people who
are like oh well now I got to put my
payment information in here like why
would I do that if I'm not a business or
if I'm not someone who's actually I mean
that because that's that's the only way
that you actually pay Twitter right now
is through advertising if I'm a person
and I want to run ads on Twitter I pay I
go through the Twitter ads portal and
then I pay for ads and that's how well I
mean you can do the Twitter blue but
that is a complete flaw right so that's
yeah that's the whole thing and that's
where this whole like Eight dollar
verification is coming through but the
other thing that's happening is um
he wants uh I guess there's this idea
out there uh that he wants to charge
people the ability to send celebrities
and other high profile people DMS so if
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait yep
I I actually see this going south
immediately when you say that and here's
why
the celebrities are probably not going
to be on that app to get [ __ ] DMS
from people that they don't want them
from yeah exactly what so so so when you
take all the athletes all the Hollywood
celebrities that people go watch uh the
actors the the TV shows the the
everything out there that people love
musicians I mean this has nothing to do
with Left Right politics that we're
talking about right right this is this
is just people wanting wanting to
message their favorite celebrity which I
I don't have a problem with but I'm sure
the celebrity doesn't want unsolicited
[ __ ] messages like they would much
rather do it in a control manner where
they can actually respond because that's
the other thing too is so you're just
gonna dump thousands of messages into
someone's DMS and then not be able to
respond so then then what it just yeah
it's it's it just goes out into the
ether it is it incredibly asinine uh I'm
sure here look I'm gonna say this is
this his idea or was this someone else's
idea that he was like yeah that that's a
good idea in the replies I'm gonna check
into that like he's been doing that a
lot late yeah I don't know if it was him
or one of his lieutenants that have come
in from you know from one of these
various organizations or other VCS
that'd be like we got to make money how
do we make money let's charge people and
they're like what interactions on this
app can we charge people for and one of
them was I guess also someone at the New
York Times has seen the mock-ups for
this because they described it as like
in early prototype so Twitter user has
was depicted asking musician post Malone
about his favorite records and I guess
they go into a separate area so you
would know like these are all the paid
people but like why the [ __ ] would I
ever go there right well again I'm not
opposed to like someone like post Malone
saying hey I want to hear from my fans
no that's totally fine yeah right but if
it's unsolicited right when you're when
you're charging when you're charging the
person who's messaging the this other
person for an unsolicited DM that seems
really [ __ ] weird and creepy number
one number two it seems like post Malone
would be like
um how many thousands DMS do I have that
I can't respond to I'm just gonna go
ahead and just take off and not do this
app yeah it's the it is the easiest way
for a bunch of people who would actually
pay to keep their
check mark
uh to say yeah [ __ ] this noise I'm out
right and they'll go somewhere else
right and they'll be an alternative and
then obviously the fans will want to
know where do I go to here this can't be
one that this can't be on the list
though right they've got they had had
the 86 this by now I it sounds like
based on this article that I read from
New York Times it sounds like that was
something they are still trying to
figure out because right now they're
like you'd be able to send at least this
is something they're exploring but these
are the types of ideas like I I've said
this before Elon Musk is not an inventor
he didn't eat something [ __ ] he is not
Reinventing the wheel he is not coming
up with brand new ideas what he wants to
do is copying WeChat over to Twitter the
problem is that the guy is literally
throwing [ __ ] on the wall and he's
trying to see what sticks and the first
thing that hit the wall and like slip
down and made a [ __ ] mess was
charging people twenty dollars then you
got in that spot with Stephen King and
then it was eight dollars and it's a
whole roundabout way of this guy
basically showing you that this guy
doesn't know know what he's doing he is
out of his element he doesn't you know
about [ __ ]
he doesn't you don't talk about [ __ ] I
don't know what movie that's from but I
can't find this clip of uh Donald Trump
which we're gonna move on here because
we really got to get to the bonehead
week so let's do this let's go to a
break when we come back we will do
bonehead of the week everyone stick
around bonehead of the week right after
these messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment we're
[Music]
to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
for this phone end of the week
bonehead of the week your favorite
segment every single Friday in the
second hour we're at the bottom of the
second hour maybe we'll do a fast round
bonehead of the week we always say that
but then then it ends up being way more
than just a I mean we can go for it we
can go for 30 minutes if you want do you
got do you got do you got time do you
got time yeah you got time okay okay why
don't we go in between we'll just try to
figure that out okay yeah that's fine
yeah that's fine so let's let's start
let's go to the music everyone loves the
music to begin with so let's go to the
music for bonehead of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to this edition of bonehead of
the week I'm your host Tony Michaels and
my co-host Gabe Sanchez with Addie the
Tony Michaels podcast you're joining us
every single Friday here on the Tony
Michaels podcast and the replay on the
Midas touch Network
if you're on the Tony Michaels podcast
or not go subscribe now to the Tony
Michaels podcast we bring you our
podcast every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific on YouTube Twitter and twitch
you are not going to want to miss it
make sure you subscribe and if you're
watching this bonehead of the week on
the replay of the miners touch Network
make sure and hit the Subscribe button
there as well if you want to vote Gabe
for bone in a week if you want to vote
for it while Twitter is still a thing
yeah you might want to go far at Tony
Michael's pod while the lights are still
on yeah why the lights are still on over
there and they're not getting this the
they're sued in the bankruptcy go follow
at Tony Michael's pod while there's
still a Twitter you will be able to vote
over there you can also vote on our
YouTube channel so again go subscribe to
the Tony Michaels podcast you can also
download bonehead of the week every
single Sunday we put it on Apple Spotify
Google don't forget to download every
single episode of the Tony Michaels
podcast while you're there and subscribe
and leave us a great review
Gabe who are our boneheads of the week
oh boy
we've got cats got some newcomers here
yeah we we've got we've got a new one on
the list we've got uh cash I've got bug
eyes Patel uh we've got rep uh four-toe
Taylor green she is she is she's quite a
contender she's won this yeah yeah she's
won this poll several times she has
definitely
um I mean look when when it's almost
like she's always got her third toe in
the race like she's just dipping it
dipping it in the race I mean look
memories whenever she's whenever she's
on bonehead of the the week like yeah
it's almost a Surefire thing that what
she's done is like
right enough that someone's like yep
that yeah no for sure right because just
like every day normal you know Tuesday
for Marjorie Taylor green is enough to
win the bonehead week but what you're
saying is when we choose her for bone of
the week it's because she is an absolute
[ __ ] bonehead that week like she has
done something really dumb exactly and
then we've got uh Laura Ingraham uh the
GOP has never said or done anything
violent in
just ever ever ever ever in the history
of ever ever ever ever
there's not one that's never have
Republicans have never said a thing this
is a done something violent they have
never done anything violent they've
never promoted violence they have never
advocated for violence they have never
done anything that would imply that the
Republican party wants violence
something makes me think there's a video
I'm just saying oh it sounds like you're
you're saying that she may have said
this on video and there's video to maybe
I mean prove or disprove it here
typically that's always the case with
with Laura Ingraham well let's let's
take a look let's start there why why
not shall we start there
um look here I found a video oh it says
hashtag violent GOP it's my Midas Touch
look at that oh so if you're here on the
Mindless touch Network you probably have
seen this video but we're going to
replay it because
it's worth a watch let's let's see what
um see what Laura the um the the Nazi
I'm not I'm not making this up her
brother says that yeah yeah so Laura
Ingraham the Nazi let's see what she has
to say about Republicans and violence
now which Republican official or
candidate has ever condoned or in any
way encouraged any type of violent
assault can you can you start naming
them I can't like to punch him in the
face I'll tell you knock the crap out of
him maybe he should have been roughed up
they never name names because they can't
foreign
[Applause]
and we want her out they never name
names because they can't that is a
depiction of Representative gosar
carrying swords attacking Alexandria
ocasio-cortez they never named name
let's have trial by combat today is the
day American Patriots start taking down
names and kicking ass we will
quietly
here in the heart of liberals everywhere
folks get on the phone call your
Congressman you can lightly threaten
them I'm coming after you Madison
cawthorne's coming after you everybody
this is getting worse game yeah this
isn't looking good
[Music]
Springfield
truly drained until we've nailed the
hides of the alligators to the wall they
never name names because they can't
second term kicks off with fine ray
flying vouching I'd put the heads on
pipes right I put them at the two
corners of the White House as a warning
you don't fight like hell you're not
gonna have a country anymore
now which Republican official or
candidate has ever condoned or in any
way encourage any type of violent
assault can you can you start naming
them I can
yeah no literally they just did they
literally just did the guy that you were
the guy that you were trying to get to
calm down on January 6th the guy that
literally said we gotta fight like hell
we gotta do like all these people that
are in that party we're taking names and
kicking ass and we will not go Silence
of the night again she's texting Mark
Meadows who is Donald Trump's chief of
staff and after which he riled up and
inside of that crowd and said I'm gonna
walk down with you which he didn't
though he did want to and then he had a
little fit in the in the SUV and tried
to choke out the Secret Service with his
title
his tiny little hands tiny little hands
right his title hand he tried to choke
he's like ah Gabe Sanchez with the tiny
hand props
um so it's just funny because here's the
thing again
they make a claim and there's always a
video to debunk that claim and I just
want to point out one comment that I saw
in here from fake games oh fake game oh
boy question mark now which Republican
official or candidate has ever condoned
or in any way encouraged any type of
violence can you start naming them I
can't uh they literally just did right
they literally just showed you videos
they didn't they didn't have to like be
like okay Donald Trump said this on this
date they just showed you like what he
said or it's not like oh there was an
interview and it's in print it's like no
no here's it in 4k in case you want to
do the whole fake news that's not what
she said that's not what she said that's
not what they meant anything it's a deep
fake I don't know I mean you can always
count on fake gay being in the comments
doing the Trump copy machine who do we
have next because it really seems like
that's an easy one on Laura ingerham
like that one's easy like yeah slam dunk
boom done boom we've got we've got cash
Patel cash Patel what did cash Patel do
what did he do this week now he's done a
lot of bone-headed things right he's
been a bonehead for a long time but this
week specifically this week specifically
he seemed to run straight into the
bonehead wall right because for weeks
and weeks and weeks he kept saying
things on Trader TV news networks like
oh Trump Declassified documents with his
mind he just rethought it and boom it
was Declassified
what happened this week well this if you
[ __ ] around and find out yeah yeah and
we've brought it up before there's a
clip uh maybe I can find it a little bit
but there's a clip of him on Fox News
where he literally admits to being there
when Trump was doing his magic hand
his his little magic hand waving
Abracadabra Kofi this is now uh
Declassified type of ritual or whatever
he did right and he admitted he said I
was there in November in December or
December and January and I was there
with Trump and I literally witnessed
this thing I was in the office and
everyone online was like uh dude why did
you just say that was the dumbest thing
you could have said why did you admit to
being there while he's doing something
that he does not have the authority
because obviously at that point the doj
was like I'm sorry come again like you
want to say that one more time got it
okay cool we've got you on tape saying
this so easily a person of interest and
so now what he did as of yesterday he
has testified before a grand jury in the
Mar-A-Lago documents case
wait a second wait a second are you
saying are you saying he's testifying to
help Trump because that seems no
whoa whoa whoa well wait that's I now I
recall the story you're talking about he
received limited use immunity in this
document's case is that the thing you're
saying is that the thing that that's
exactly what I'm saying
so cash Patel receives limited use
immunity uh to for his test of his
testimony which he did yesterday correct
I think that's he actually testified
yesterday
um to the doj and he made a deal with
the doj and the FBI for this limited use
immunity which if anyone goes and just
does a little bit of research just
Google it read I don't know about 30 40
seconds to realize what limited use
immunity is
um it means the person who is granted
The Limited use immunity has committed
crimes that's what they're being immune
from right is crimes so the the fact
that it's even out in the public that
this guy is going to testify in this
case where Donald Trump stole our
classified documents from us our
government stored them in a very
unsecure place in his desk drawer and on
the floor and then melania's underwear
drawer the reason why cash Patel had to
make sure to get limited use immunity
from crimes is I would imagine it has to
do with these documents it probably
isn't something else that's the also the
other thing you have to understand about
limited use right immunity and it really
does feel like cash would probably not
go on like a Trader News Network like
one that's called like real America's
voice after he's done this deal and try
to demonize the people that he did a
deal with but he is a [ __ ] bonehead
so that's why he's on the bone of the
week so here is a great it's 16 seconds
you don't get much more bone-headedness
in this 16 seconds but let's watch it
one doj and FBI across the board to
eliminate this two-tier system of
justice that they have created you must
must must investigate and seize the
appropriate funding from these
institutions until they comply with the
law
there it is there it is Cash Mattel
obviously telling us that hey the reason
why I made the deal is because I have
limited use immunity because I commended
federal crimes and I'm trying to be
amazed from and oh by the way go vote
for Republicans that way they can smash
up our democracy and get rid of the the
justice system which is going to hold me
accountable because that's the other
thing about limited use immunity Gabe
um and I I think it's not been talked
about enough is that cash Patel is only
limited to a certain amount of charges
here it's it's a limited use Immunity on
some of these uh crimes that he's
obviously committed that the doj has
evidence of otherwise his lawyers would
not be negotiating negotiating this
limited use exactly and obviously this
is one of those things where all you
know he can still if he wants to [ __ ]
around and find out more right if he
were to I don't know try to commit
perjury under which which we will find
out yeah yeah because this judge this
judge if this judge gets any kind of
[ __ ] whiff that he committed perjury
or that he withheld testimony or
anything he he will be held in civil uh
contempt which means they can jail him
so
um which is even worse for him like
these are all of these people are the
same way they either say yeah I'll be
willing to testify and or I'll you know
I'll go in front of a whatever and I'll
I'll give my [ __ ] and then they're you
know subpoenaed or they have a
uh they they sit down you know for a
deposition or something and all they do
is plead the fifth right Free Speech but
I'm gonna plead the fifth I do not want
to incriminate myself because
I did something that was bad guys I did
a boo-boo I made a bad owie I did
something very very bad illegal that I
know was wrong when I committed the
crime that I planned to commit
and still did the crime and now that I
was caught for doing the crime
I don't want to talk about these other
crimes that I also did that you might or
might not know about
and so every one of them you've got John
Eastman Roger Stone big tough guy you've
got cash pot Stewart Rhodes today in
trial testifying in open court saying
yeah I did want a qrf there in case
Trump We need he declared martial law
and we needed to deputize people like he
literally said it in open court that
they their plan was to use the qrf if
Trump gave him orders right which is
insanity to me but he said it in open
course
that is that you know and I don't know
if if you know even on the quickly on
the Stuart Road saying like I don't know
if Stewart's like [ __ ] it like if I say
everything maybe I'll get out of this
some way or maybe like Maybe me telling
the truth will help me in some way I
have no idea but it is interesting to
see him reveal all this stuff and be
like yep there there was this and there
was that and there was this
communication that communication
meanwhile all these other people who are
the higher ups are like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] and they're all the ones who
are you know oh actively avoiding
getting served to subpoena they're
actively uh pleading the fifth when they
can even though they say they would tell
you everything that happened uh they've
got nothing to hide they're not a
criminal they're innocent uh this is a a
witch hunt again if these things were
um unfairly like done to you and you
actually were innocent you would you
would hope that you'd be like yeah let
me let me [ __ ] spill my guts here and
tell you exactly what happened because
it's not what you're claiming or
accusing me of but none of these people
actually want to talk because they know
that they are in the wrong and they've
known that the whole time but again they
just continue to Griff money from people
because they say I'm innocent it's a
Witch Hunt this is fake news uh Tish
James is after me and they're coming
after me in Georgia and the mar-a-lagos
those are my documents all of it is
[ __ ] what a whiny little [ __ ] what
a whiny little [ __ ] you know who else
is a whiny little [ __ ] this guy he
ended up on the alpha
how did Dr maimon odds get Alpha cuck
this week you know it took it took
longer than I thought right but Oprah
the woman who essentially wait wait wait
you mean like the Oprah like Oprah
Winfrey Oprah Oprah Winfrey you know has
had her Studio still has her Studio I
don't know but definitely had Harpo
studios in Chicago right uh where I'm
from right and she created two there
were two people that she really created
and they're both kind of garbage right
yeah they're both like
doctors in a way right I mean obviously
Dr Oz doctor but I like put these really
big air quotes around it uh you've got
the doctor Junior thing where you put
quotes the entire time that you're
talking because for whatever reason I
don't know what Junior it was like he
had like a little bunny show it looked
like that when he was like I'm like I'm
gonna do some shadow puppets but I have
to do them at night but I did them in a
day he keeps doing it though like he the
entire time that he talks
it's on another level the reason I think
the reason he's like you know uh is
because he is
probably on a bender you know a little
still little like still a little wired
he's like after a late night of uh of I
don't know what he does
um I don't want to know what he does
right but anyway but here's the thing
though here's the thing though it's is
it really that hard to imagine that
Oprah would endorse John Federman after
after seeing who's endorsing Dr Oz I
mean this isn't common no right and I
don't and I don't know like here's the
thing I wish that she would have said
something earlier I wish that she would
have said more actually because I think
I think you're right during the
primaries when she should have said
something she should have altered like
that could have been something that was
a nail in the coffin to be like boom
this Trump endorsed candidate Dr Oz this
guy who is you know killed puppies and
uh wants to talk about a [ __ ] veggie
plate in a fancy way and wants to attack
John fetterman for this and that like
all of these things
you would you would in my mind I would
hope so I you know others would hope
that she should have said something
early on like cut it like you know right
because it's obvious that that Dr Oz
wouldn't be who he is right now without
Oprah oh not at all and I'm not I'm not
blaming Oprah for this situation right
like a lot of people I've seen that a
lot now now I mean she did create these
two right like they were just doctors
they were a guest on the show and then
they're like oh we got some we got
something going on here we should give
you something right but but Oprah isn't
responsible for every single vile those
two humans have done but what I am
saying is that
um she did help give them a platform
they wouldn't be who they were without
her not at all but at the same time
maybe maybe Oprah is very strategic
about this and maybe just maybe we are
completely wrong because I actually see
the argument in the another Direction
completely is that she's striking and
the very last moment yes that's where
fetterman does need a lot of support and
needs people to go okay that's enough
for me to get my ass up and go vote
because I think I think this election
the story that's going to be told next
week by the end of next week
is that this is an election of turnout
right this this isn't a this isn't a
matter of rather the majority of the
country wants these [ __ ] bashes to to
be in power we already had that election
and that was before January 6th even
happened right that was before the big
lie was even was even brought on our
country our country decided we don't
want to do that right so I think that
this is just a strategic move for Oprah
to endorse fetterman for turnout right I
mean maybe maybe I'm completely off here
but no no I do see the argument both
ways right right and she should have
been speaking before but this
endorsement for veteran in this moment I
don't think is a bad thing I think it's
more good than it is bad so yeah I mean
as we you know next week Tuesday we've
got an election and uh if anyone didn't
know that uh it's kind of a big deal
right now no one's heard on our Channel
or Midas
happening for 2022 a lot of a lot of
seats a lot a lot of things at stake
guys a lot of a lot of Rights women's
rights uh uh people who are not white
voting rights you know keeping children
safe in schools anyway a lot of things
that are at stake right and I I
completely agree I think that this move
in last minute you know is an effective
tool now the next thing I'm curious to
see is is she on the campaign Trail does
she make an appearance or say something
like I don't condone you know I condemn
what you know Dr Oz is doing or what
he's done in the past yeah we'll see but
there's possibility she she does go to a
campaign rally over the weekend as we
lead into like as another like nail in
to be like oh what okay one thing she
could touch on right like she could
speak about Dr Oz in a way because she
knows him not just uh personally but
professionally here and she basically
made him what he is today yeah um
without her he may not be
even a Senate candidate
um but I think one thing she can speak
on that I think will have a huge effect
and what if she does campaign over the
weekend to absolutely bury the shiv and
twist it you know with all her might is
to talk about how much of a fraud he is
yeah because I think that's the one
thing that pennsylvanians absolutely
hate about that guy more than anything
else is that he's not even from
Pennsylvania doesn't live there it's all
[ __ ] it's all phony when he puts on
like the eagles you know the Eagles
jerseys when he's when he clearly is
like a Cowboys fan yeah and he's putting
on the Eagles early he he he's been
acting like he's a Phillies fan and just
it's just it's just fake as [ __ ] right
yeah and so I think she more than anyone
could probably really close that deal
and close that argument for
pennsylvanians
um possibly but let's listen here here's
a audio of her endorsing Federal I said
it was up to the citizens of
Pennsylvania and of course but I will
tell you all this if I lived in
Pennsylvania I would have already asked
my vote for John fetterman for many
reasons so for many reasons she would
have cast her vote for John Federer it's
great if she could right maybe do it in
person to explain the many reasons right
and I think I think maybe that maybe
that is the last move yeah that um that
Oprah makes in this endorsement possibly
so that's that's what led us for Dr Oz
to be Alpha cut this week because I I
also think that there's a bit of a
tactic here like if she were to go out
and say something over the weekend I
don't know if he has any I haven't
looked at the rallies but if he has a
rally this weekend or a fundraiser or
something like an event either Saturday
Sunday or Monday you know
there might be something where John
fetterman says great we've got that on
tape
and we literally just post that
everywhere we make an ad for it we buy
ad spots we put it on Twitter we put it
on you know Facebook Instagram
everywhere you can think of we use her
words against him
to say why them of the many reasons
right they just go a b c d e f g like
all the reasons why he would not be a
good uh represent or a senator of the
state of Pennsylvania especially because
he doesn't live in Pennsylvania he's
from New Jersey in a mansion very nice
looking looking at all
one of his one of his Mansions so let's
talking about say speaking about a rich
person there's a rich person in the news
a lot here lately he apparently bought
some unknown social media property I
don't know for a couple bucks or
something
or no parlor or that one it starts with
a T I believe Twitter Twitter that's it
this guy he's the dishonorable mention
today Elon Musk he's probably the
dishonorable mention every day really
honestly um you know the the sad part
about Elon Musk is they all claim he's
so smart and so intelligent such a great
big business person but Gabe he doesn't
understand capitalism he just doesn't
get it he doesn't get it he's now I
don't know that he's ever got it he
tweeted this morning he was crying the
whole time here's what he said and I'm
gonna try to I'm gonna try to give you
my best Elon Musk while he was typing
this out okay bear with me
Twitter Twitter has had a massive drop
in Revenue
due to activist groups pressuring
advertisers even though nothing has
changed with the content moderation and
we did everything we could to appease
the activist
extremely messed up
they're trying to destroy free speech in
America
he really is a [ __ ] Karen isn't he oh
my God what a [ __ ] what a little [ __ ]
capitalism is a [ __ ]
I mean oh my God you love Free Speech
they they exercise their free speech
what did they say they said we don't
want to work with you
bye-bye sucks to suck Elon yeah look
here's the thing is that when when he
made this [ __ ] stupid ass comment
that he was gonna buy Twitter to free
speech in America he did not think past
those characters when he hit the Tweet
button and his entire [ __ ] incel simp
Army pressured him into actually buying
it yeah because we know that he didn't
actually want to buy this [ __ ] thing
he tried to back out several times up
until the very last minute he was trying
to back out and now today he's firing
how many employees from Twitter 3 700
employees well most of them it's illegal
for him to fire them at this point how
he's doing it right all right yeah how
he's doing it I think when the
uh I think what was revealed in the
slack channel on for the Twitter company
slack Channel it was like 37-18
something around there but basically
said like 30 seconds almost 4 000 right
right and that's the thing like I've
talked about I didn't specifically say
what it was called but it was the it's
the warn act and
for anyone who doesn't know so in
California which is uh where I live it's
very it's like as Pro there are two
things California does they protect
tenants like to the nth degree and they
protect employees to the nth degree they
have so many protocols and laws in place
that basically will be like if you do
something against an employee they will
come after you and your family like
that's the amount of protection that
they can that they have right and so
what happens is you've got Elon Musk he
buys Twitter there's some mention
earlier on he's going to lay these he's
going to lay a percentage off and he's
going to let go and he's going to
restart the company do all the [ __ ] but
the issue is that this is a California
company right so in California you've
got
people that are employees and there's a
California's warn Law requires Twitter
to give you 60 days notice of a massive
layoff now I'm not a mathematician but 3
700 people seems like a pretty massive
layoff right well not only that there's
a law in Australia for the the the the
Twitter employees in Australia that
they're gonna probably bring a class
action lawsuit that's very similar it's
a very similar type labor law in
Australia so now he's gonna have he's
gonna have many lives it's an
international
[ __ ] because here's the thing if
you have 50 50 plus employees within a
30-day period that qualifies all right
so a layoff of 50 plus employees within
a 30-day period qualifies none of these
people here here's the other thing no
one at this company could have received
a 30-day 60-day type of notice when Elon
just got the company at the end of
October
so again I'm no mathematician but if
it's November 4th and he got the company
at the end of October doesn't really
equal 30 or even so it wasn't their
first notice like last night in an email
like literally that was the first
official notice yeah I mean I mean he he
had floated this but that that doesn't
prove [ __ ] just because you said it out
just because you Declassified it with
your mind it doesn't matter you're gonna
have an official notice the note is the
email went out and
uh and I just sent it to you if you want
to pull it out yeah but the email went
out and basically was like hey uh
tomorrow everyone's gonna find out if
they still have a job via email now I've
seen some cold [ __ ] ways to that
people have done this like again I've
worked in SF I've worked for startups
I've survived the layoffs been part of
the layoffs like that's the that's the
way that business is right but the way
in which people conduct a layoff is
telling of who's actually running the
company you'll have in-person stuff
that's one version we actually talk to
someone in person and they say hey
here's the severance package here's the
here's the requirements you have this
much time to sign this and agree to it
if you have any issues then you know we
can discuss and uh you've been cut off
Access wise your computer your email all
this stuff whatever
another way uh is you lay off a ton of
people via Zoom that happened uh I think
that happened in 2019 or 2020 like bird
was one of them people walked into an
all hands meeting
the HR rep had their screen off so
didn't even look at these people in the
eye on a [ __ ] camera and said you're
all fired
and then there's another way which is
basically sending an email like Elon did
here and sent an email saying we
acknowledge this incredibly challenging
experience to go through whether you are
impacted or not thank you for continuing
to adhere to Twitter policies and that
prohibit you from discussing
confidential information and social
media with the presser also basically
like don't talk will come after you the
other if you go to the first page for
the first like kind of snippet the line
in here of that is just like wow uh is
they say please if you scroll down
they go uh please check your email
including your spam folder like you
would hope that if you're getting an
email from the company you work for Via
your Twitter email
Twitter would figure it out to be like
great we're not going to flag these
things to go into your spam folder
almost like they're a technology company
or something yeah it's almost like uh I
don't know a guy who says he's a genius
bought a company that was overvalued and
then tried to make money but realize
that people are always working with a
genius genius he's a genius so in here
you've got people that are literally
waiting
to get an email today to say Your Role
at like your role at Twitter just super
ominous Your Role at Twitter and then
the details of that email say you're
fired or you still have a job and you
can come in on Monday because they
closed the office on Friday so basically
they took the office down and they said
no one can come to the office you have
meetings don't show up just wait for the
email that you're gonna get so 3 700
email or 3700 emails went out to 3 700
employees saying you don't have a job
anymore goodbye
and the thing that really kills me the
most is the fact that Elon worked these
people down to the [ __ ] bone in the
last week that they were there 14 plus
hours 12 to 14 plus hours people working
sleeping on the floor sleeping on the
floor in a [ __ ] sleeping bag to get
to to make sure that they are able to
finish this arbitrary deadline because
Elon was like by November 7th you know
it seems funny the November 7th right
which is almost like there's like the
day after there's this important thing
exactly like it it seems a little bit
weird that you would pick yeah right
November 7th right and then the other
thing too is like oops maybe [ __ ] goes
down on November 8th or November 7th
there's a glitch so Twitter's down no
one can say who knows I'm not saying
that is a possible conspiracy but it is
very odd that it's like November 7th is
the that's the decision right I
guarantee you though Gabe on November
8th who will actually be able to make
sure they can type stuff in the Twitter
is the Elon Musk fans Mike points it out
here he says I don't want to make a
broad generalization but you have to
admit it's at least interesting that
everyone who likes Elon is The Biggest
Loser that you've ever met right he's
kind of spot on now this tweet blew up
right it's got a hundred thousand likes
from this screenshot from over a day ago
so he replies wow this really blew up I
feel like one of his cars
oh okay Elon that's why you get the
dishonorable mention today is because
you are a bonehead oh you're the biggest
bonehead that I think there is and you
know what's even worse again it's the
people who actually sent to this [ __ ]
and think that was really smart dude I
have I've gotten so many hate comments
of people we had we had the trolls in
the show this morning I mean it was like
pounding like they were created they had
created hundreds of accounts to troll us
this morning oh man she has to come on
and I I would imagine that they were
really upset about our Elon thumbnail
this morning the picture that we used
maybe it was Elon Elon sitting in there
yeah he might have I mean maybe we're on
the radar but I mean like the thing is
you just can't one you just can't treat
people like [ __ ] and then expect stuff
from them and then also if you treat
people like [ __ ] you can't get mad when
they say yeah I'm done I don't want to
work with you so you cannot get mad at
advertisers when you lose a stream of
Revenue and people who are simping for
Elon and want to defend him you can't
get mad at me when I've been calling
this [ __ ] out all week and last week
when I've literally been telling telling
you he bought it he doesn't know what
he's doing and now he's literally
overworking employees and then people in
the comments which I think is [ __ ]
crazy
is the amount of people they should have
to work 500 hours a week right there's
people like I had three jobs and raised
two kids it's like but yeah that's the
point you shouldn't have to have three
jobs to raise children we shouldn't have
to which I think which I think for the
upcoming election it is something to
remember
that when you are sitting there or
standing there at the pole and you're
voting for who you want to you know
choose to to be your representative
Senator uh local politician or just you
know whatever
you want to vote blue and the reason you
want to vote blue is because Republicans
are the ones who don't want to give you
a raise in your minimum wage they don't
want to give you benefits when it comes
to uninsurance they don't want to give
you a relief at the gas pump they don't
want to help you with inflation they
don't want to do anything that would
help you as a person survive in this
crazy [ __ ] of a country that we
call the United States that is the
end-all be-all truth Republicans is they
they are they are fighting against you
because they want to selfishly support
themselves and as a result they're
hurting you they're oppressing you and
that's not just me telling it literally
look at all the things they want to do
anti-lgbtq legislation uh pro-gun
legislation
um they they want to raise uh or take
away taxes for the wealthy take away
Medicare and and
um any all of these other social
programs that help us As Americans those
are things they want to take away and
this example right here of Elon getting
butt hurt because people decided to
choose what they wanted to do
and then blaming someone is exactly the
same thing that the Republican party is
doing they're blaming they will blame
watch when the pull when when the votes
come in they're gonna play the victim
and they're gonna blame everyone and
they're gonna they're gonna call it a
fake and they're gonna do this and do
that because they can't acknowledge the
fact that they're just shitty humans and
some Americans have now decided they're
shitty humans and they don't want to
actually work with them anymore they
don't want to support them Gabe speaking
of shitty humans speaking of garbage
human beings
hey look who else is on the uh bone end
of the week she I don't know how many
times she's won this she has to Bear a
record holder for sure oh yeah I think
she's she's got a trophy she's gonna be
she's got to be the bonehead of all time
I think she's only lost one time but
that she was on the pole like yesterday
when we were you know trying to figure
out who was going to be on this thing I
was like because of what she said last
night at the rally and that's what we're
going to show here that why she's a
bonehead but I was like she's a Surefire
winner she's a Surefire winner of this
poll that she's a bonehead and she did
not disappoint she is the bonehead of
the week
um and the reason why Gabe is you posted
it um earlier or well actually last
night I believe
um this video here you said Marjorie
Taylor green our country comes first
sorry must have missed the part where
the GOP actually cared about Americans
um here's one of the clips I'm going to
show you a couple different ones but
here's one of them let's listen the only
border they care about is Ukraine
not America's Southern border
under Republicans not another Penny will
go to Ukraine
[Applause]
our country comes first
they don't care about our border or our
people so there you have it um Putin's
party is Now official so go if you like
Vladimir Putin as your leader if you
like Vladimir Putin the murders dictator
as your friend your foe or your friend
and your ally you love him go vote
Republican if you think he's a murderous
dictator who is a threat to not just uh
Ukraine's democracy but democracy around
the world then I would suggest that you
do what Gabe said and vote blue and
there's a couple other Clips here that
makes her look
um disgusting which isn't
difficult at this point but um here she
is getting the crown to cheer about
Nancy Pelosi and her husband
where Americans are robbed stabbed raped
kidnapped carjacked and murdered but
only the only crime victim you hear
about from Democrats in the media is
Paul Pelosi
[Music]
Paul Pelosi was brutally attacked by
drugged out illegal alien that should
have been deported and Paul Pelosi
should have been a gun owner and shot
his attacker
this is really
oh what a bonehead all right there's a
lot of there's a lot of stuff there's a
lot of stupidity the beginning part
really quickly just the beginning part
she says there's this crime they want to
do this they rape they do all the first
off one if someone is unfortunately
raped that is something a Republican
party says nah [ __ ] it we don't really
care they won't do anything about it if
you're raped and you get pregnant the
Republican Party says carry that baby
[ __ ] all the way to term even if
it's even if it's your life [ __ ] you
they literally are telling everyone from
a 10 year old 12 year old to a a 30 year
old woman saying hey look uh maybe that
was like your fault that you did that
right there they completely what were
you what were you wearing wearing what
were you doing what did you tell them
how did you respond it's like whoa whoa
why are we why are we blaming the victim
like actually blaming the victim and by
the way by the way there a lot of
instances where it's medically necessary
it doesn't have to be nefarious to
receive this but I want to show you a
clip here yeah now we we showed it it
was shown earlier on the video uh with
Laura Ingram but I think it it fits well
right here where she is
um talking about how an illegal alien I
love how I love how this Canadian who
was here on Avis who overstayed his Visa
who's been Dukes he's believing [ __ ]
like like chewing on
um and he's talking about shooting her
own people right listen listen to this
voice on this video and tell me if you
can recognize it she's a traitor to our
country she's guilty of treason she took
enough to protect American citizens and
uphold our laws and she gives Aid and
comfort to our enemies who illegally
invade our land that's what treason is
exactly and by our law representatives
and Senators can be kicked out and no
longer serve in our government and it's
a it's a crime punishable by death okay
so there she actually invokes the
illegal immigrant kind of thing but in
the opposite direction did you notice
that did you notice that she's like
she's treasonous because she's letting
the illegals in and we should hang her
for it because the penalty she also says
treason is something where they were
moved by office punishable by death and
it's like the projection right of this
woman who was part of the January 6th
Insurrection who's that I didn't know
what was going on but in December was
coming back from media and said oh we
got to stop the steel rally and this and
that like you're actively pushing the
big lie and you're actively a part of
this Coalition coup
to go against their our own
self-interest our own country so it is
it's it's just like this is what the
[ __ ] Republican party is they don't
care about you the one last thing I want
to mention is the other comments she
made at the rally about the gun now what
she what she said about the gun is
[ __ ] Rich because papalosi is still
alive he's still alive he's still alive
now yes he did get smashed in the hammer
because people like Marjorie Taylor
green and cite violence and incite
people who believe crazy delusional [ __ ]
to go to people's houses and smash them
in the head with a hammer but he's still
alive
so he didn't need a gun he didn't need a
gun I just want to point that out but
Marjorie Taylor green you never
disappoint on bonehead of the week you
really don't you're almost a Surefire
winner here at the Tony Michaels podcast
when our audience votes for bone net of
the week every single week
your Surefire winner let's give her her
do again
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you not even a competition really
game oh dude like cheap out front I I
know wait I wish someone else is gonna
win uh it was just last night before I
went to bed I was like all right great
you know it's got about like six four
hours left on the pole uh I think we're
good and it was I mean like nothing
really changed there were some there
were some additional things that were
added like in terms of like where it
laid out but it was like by one to two
percent in each of them like they
fluctuated we were trying to figure this
out because we were we were thinking
about Trump because some of the [ __ ] you
know with all the right with all the
document [ __ ] and all the the the Tish
James and the judge's decision I'm sure
he's gonna be he's gonna
either it's the cases he's gonna he's
gonna have to testify or it's gonna be
this potential I'm announcing that I'm
running for 2025 oh which is even more
bone-headed [ __ ] yeah even more bonus so
he'll be he'll be on the list again for
sure but we were we were you know
floating all that around and then I came
across the video of her talking about
the Ukraine and basically being Putin's
puppet I'm like well there it is yeah
and I I sent I sent you the video I'm
like put her on there and I'm like she's
a Surefire winner and you the audience
did not disappoint and I think it's just
because we know this all too well she is
the biggest bonehead of all the
boneheads so everyone make sure to vote
every single week for bone of the week
on Twitter as long as there's still a
Twitter at Tony Michael's pod but also
also subscribe to the Tony Michaels
podcast our YouTube channel you can vote
on the community tab every single week
there as well and right now if you're
watching this because every single
Friday Gabe we air bonehead a week in
the second hour the Tony Michaels
podcast and it replays on the minus
touch Network so if you're watching this
on a Midas Touch Network right now make
sure you hit that subscribe button it is
super easy so you do not miss a single
minus touch Network video and also you
can download you can download Bona of
the week on the weekends on Sunday but
download every single episode of the
Tony Michaels podcast super important
you don't want to miss it every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on YouTube
Twitter and twitch and simulcasting from
the Midas touch fate was Facebook page
also our Facebook page yeah and Gabe I
gotta say it's getting cold outside one
last thing before we go here on bonehead
it's getting cold outside and so if
anyone needs to stay warm while you're
waiting in line yeah this has been a hot
item over on the merch store go to
store.dtonymichaels.com that's
store.thetonymichaels.com get your
Liberty hoodie
pullover hoodie sweater jacket there's
also t-shirts go check out our merch
store store not be tonymichaels.com you
are our support everyone if you're
watching on the podcast stick around
we're going to talk a few more minutes
but if you're on the minus touch Network
this has been this week's edition of
bonehead
of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
bonehead of the week
that that she's a Surefire win every
[ __ ] green you can always rely on
marketing
about like getting our getting a
Snapchat or a screenshot of our chat
just to prove to everyone that we knew
oh yeah we we almost know when she goes
on she's gonna win no [ __ ] question
uh who because who knows I mean you know
come Tuesday uh she might only have a
few months left of oh she'll still be
doing bone-headed oh yeah yeah but in
terms of actually being in awe I mean
she can't do anything she's not in any
committee
she'll be in office long enough to do
more bone into stuff to be on the boat I
mean anyway like she's not even really a
congress person at this point anyways
like she's not on any committee she
doesn't have any I mean she can go to
the floor and yell and screaming and and
actually introduce amendments there but
that that's the only thing that she has
is the floor of the house that's it
um so
she definitely is going to be a
contender I'm sure verbon in the week as
she is every week but she is a Surefire
winner for sure for sure
Gabe this has been a a very very very
very very great week in news it really
has I mean we've seen such great things
in news I know a lot of people are
disappointed about this Merrick Garland
thing maybe we'll talk about it more
next week I think though what you need
to do this weekend folks it's most
important because I always tell you have
a safe weekend before we go but this is
most important we are down to the wire
here
and we watch videos this morning and
really uh let me pull it up why we're
sitting here of gen Z this is uh at the
UT uh Austin the University of Texas
Austin
um this is and I'll that that's not what
I wanted
I don't know why yeah ah I'm on the
wrong tab that's why
um this is the University of Austin
um these students are lined up and
they're ready to vote and you know you
know that the majority of them are going
to protect their rights for their
Futures because they have their entire
Futures ahead of them the entire thing
um so here is Here's the the video of
the line so I'm I'm telling you no
matter what generation you're in no
matter no matter what your Creed your
religion no matter what your affiliation
lean into your democracy we are down to
the wire here it is so important that
you engage and we have talked about it
every single day that you must find
three people to encourage to vote just
three and then encourage those three to
find uh three more to encourage and once
you find those three and you feel
confident that you've encouraged them
and they took your your encouragement to
Heart find three more it is super
important that everyone goes and has
their vote cast I really don't care who
you vote for frankly Gabe I wish every
single person who is eligible to vote
would vote in this election so this this
country and really the world would know
that we do not want this trumpism [ __ ]
we are tired of this trumpism [ __ ] and I
really feel like the turnout is there I
feel like it's on our side the
pro-democracy side generally speaking
when people go vote they believe in
democracy that is what I think is
working for us here in the pro-democracy
movement so make sure to go vote blue
but more than anything than just your
ballot that you encourage three people
find those three people family friends
colleagues fellow parishioners maybe
someone at the PTA the lady that checks
you out at the grocery store when you're
getting your milk and your bread
encourage them to go vote and explain to
them why it is so important in your view
why they vote it is super important that
we get the turnout and it seems like
we're we've got this turnout
um that we that we really need to win
this Escape for democracy
I'm just going to call what it is right
now we need to if anyone's seen the
movie Pay It Forward what we are
describing right now and I'll send a
tweet out in a second is uh and I think
I said it last week too is vote It
Forward right it's the idea that you get
three people those people get three
people those people get three like right
just continuing to have this widespread
viral approach [ __ ] coordinate
carpools get people that can vote to
vote right right you want to make sure
that everyone that has a voice is able
to use that voice and exercise their
right to vote however you want to vote
well the other thing too it would be for
blue but you know is figure out where
you're gonna vote you've got the weekend
like Texas they're not they they make it
difficult as [ __ ] to vote so over the
weekend they're not going to be able to
they're not going to be able to vote so
so if you want to early vote I think you
have to do it today right exactly yep
today is the last day of early voting in
Texas until you get to Tuesday so if you
want to early vote now is the time in
Texas so so be looking that stuff up
just simply Google it and I know I know
that sounds crazy but if you start
googling these things about where you're
going to vote how you're going to vote
what is early voting in your state you
will find it very easily just start
googling it and ask ask folks really
honestly if you ask folks there's more
engagement
that is what we must do in our democracy
right now it is it is crucial and we
have so much at stake and really it's
the rights of all of us it's the rights
of all of us to have Liberty here in
this country because if they really do
take over it's not going to be a change
that you want and I don't believe that
Americans want it and I believe I'm very
optimistic I'm very confident in your
voice and your vote
so everyone have a safe weekend figure
out where you're going to vote if you're
going to vote today if you're going to
vote over the weekend if you're going to
vote Monday Tuesday find a way but also
engage find those three people
do what democracies do best and Crush
fascism everyone have a safe weekend
Surf's Up [ __ ] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon